hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel as you know in today's
world data is becoming increasingly
important
entire professions are dedicated to
studying understanding and manipulating
the data
hence it is important to know about the
different types of data and their
associated properties
so in this session we'll discuss how to
calculate the distortion in the normal
curve using skewness and kurtosis so
let's get started
we will start this tutorial by
understanding symmetrical distribution
then we'll move on to discuss skewed
distribution and pearson's coefficient
of skewness
finally we will discuss kurtosis
so let's get started
symmetrical distribution
a distribution is said to be symmetrical
distribution when it is equally
distributed on both the sides of the
mean value
the distribution shape can either be a
bell shaped or u-shaped
in symmetrical distribution the values
of mean median and mode are all equal as
you can see in the graph
skewed distribution
skewness is used to measure the level of
asymmetry in our graph
it is a measure of asymmetry that occurs
when our data deviates from the norm
sometimes the normal distribution tends
to be tilt more on one side
this is because the probability of data
being more or less than the mean is
higher and hence makes the distribution
asymmetrical
this also means that the data is not
equally distributed
the skewers can be of two types
positively skewed and negatively skewed
let's discuss them separately
negatively skewed in a negatively skewed
distribution the data points are more
concentrated towards the right hand side
of the distribution
as you can see in the graph
this makes the mean median and mode bend
towards the right
hence these values are always negative
in this distribution mode is greater
than median and meter is greater than
mean
now let's move on to positively skewed
distribution
in a distribution that is positively
skewed the values are more concentrated
towards the right side
and the left tail is spread out as you
can see in the graph
hence
the statistical results are bent towards
the left hand side
therefore the mean median and mode are
always positive
in this distribution
mean is greater than median and median
is greater than mode
the measure of skewness always help us
to know to what degree and in which
direction positive or negative the
frequency distribution has a departure
from symmetry
positive or negative skewness can be
detected graphically depending on
whether the right tail or the left is
longer but we don't get the idea of the
magnitude
in a negatively skewed symmetry the
values are always negative
this is the symmetrical distribution and
in a positively skewed the values are
always positive
now let's discuss pierce's coefficient
of skewness
the median is always the middle value
and the mean and the mode are the
extremes
so we can derive the formula to capture
the horizontal distance between the mean
and the mode using the pearson's first
coefficient
so the formula to calculate the
pearson's coefficient is mean minus mode
divided by the standard deviation
the division by the standard deviation
will help you to scale down the
difference between the mode and the mean
this will scale down their values in the
range of minus three to plus three
in case where the mode is indeterminate
we can calculate the pearson's
coefficient
by
mean minus three median minus two mean
divided by the standard deviation
and the value of coefficient is between
minus 0.5 and 0.5 the distribution of
the value is always symmetrical
if the value of coefficient is 0 then
the distribution is symmetrical
if the value of coefficient is positive
then the distribution is positively
skewed and if the coefficient is
negative then the distribution will be
negatively skewed
now that we have discussed this
symmetrical and skew distribution let's
move on to understand what is kurtosis
kurtosis is used to find the presence of
outliers in our data
it gives us the total degree of outliers
present
the data can be heavily tailed and the
peak can be flatter almost like punching
the distribution or squishing it
while skewness signifies the extent of
the symmetry kurtosis measures the
degree of peakness of a frequency
distribution
when the peak of the curve becomes
relatively high then the curve is called
leptokortek
and when the curve is flat it is called
platyochotic
when the curve is similar to the normal
curve it is called mesocotech
the expected value of cortisone is three
this is the observed in a symmetrical
distribution a curtis is greater than
three will indicate positive vertices
further a cortex is less than three will
mean a negative kurtosis the range of
value for a negative quartosis is from
-2 to infinity
the greater the value of quartus is the
higher is the peak as you can see from
the graph
with this we come to an end to this
tutorial
let's conclude what we have learnt
you can say that is cunes and kurtosis
are used to describe the spread of
height of a normal distribution
skewness is used to denote the
horizontal pull of the data it tells you
how spread out the data is and the
cortexes is used to find the vertical
pull or the peak's height
thank you all for watching this session
we hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions feel free to put them in the
comment section of this video thank you
again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here